merci d'être là les gérer c'est
l'information du jour nicolas sarkozy
l'ancien président de la république
vient d'être condamné à trois ans de
prison dont un an ferme
deux mois après le procès de l affaire
des écoutes l'ancien président a été
reconnu coupable de corruption et de
trafic d'influencé
la question que tout le monde se pose
nicolas sarkozy va-t-il aller en prison
parce que c'est vrai que c'est la
question qu'on peut se poser
intercepté des conversations entre un
avocat et un client c'est s'en servir
pour l'autre une base
normalement non c'est comme ça la cour
de cassation s'est prononcée la
profession a était vent debout sur ses
procédés c'est peut-être ça qu'on
pourrait considérer qu'il s'agit d'un
d'un procès politique mais remettre en
cause le secret professionnel qui est
absolu normalement entre un avocat et
son client c'est porter atteinte à
l'état de droit
nicolas sarkozy renonce à présent de la
république il n'est pas au dessus des
lois
on est bien d'accord ans a déjà droit il
a droit comme tous les politiques il a
droit quand même un procès équitable
comme comment ça n'a pas été le cas le
délit n'a pas été commis lui-même
donc il est jugé ni l'intuition d'une
intention mais qui d'autre en france et
est puni de peines de prison pour
l'intention d'avoir commis un délit ça
n'existe pas coucou tpm pc loana je
tenais à vous dire que les messages que
vous avez vu ce week-end ce sont bien
les miens c'est bien moi qui les ai
écrits c'est eric qui a transmis
communaux transmis à la vidéo parce que
j'avais pas internet alors ah la la
déjà en forme là elle a le sourire et ça
c'est bien elle est hyper important
ensuite à la cus donc si dureté gars de
lui avoir volé des choses regarde par
contre je te vient rajouter à la tension
de sylvie que ma valise et étrangement
vides ils manquent de mes bijoux à vars
aux as et barda ump-udf émettant jusqu'à
mi slip
j'en ai même plus une j'ai plus de
culotte plus de fer à friser plus de
bijoux n'ai plus rien dans ma valise
la réal est vide une valise vie
étrangement es tu étais celle qui était
à côté de moi dans la chambre d'hôtel
elle fait une crise suite à des drogues
qu'elle aurait consommé et sylvie
effectivement lui aurait donné des
médicaments suite à cette crise c'est
vrai c'est ce qui s'est passé elle a
fait alors c'est pas ce que dit luan à
regarder ensuite de dire que je fais une
overdose ghb est je tiens à vous
préciser que je n'ai pas pris de drogue
que je les analyse pour le projet non ça
a été à la fois de cause de médicaments
que j'ai eu ce coma de plusieurs heures
qui aurait pu me coûter la vie si elle
était très proche si viennois vraiment
les venues d'ailleurs c'est bilingue il
faudrait trouver qu'est ce qui s'est
passé depuis lost
qu'est ce qui s'est passé ça s'est passé
que la lui a fallu une dose de
médicament quel arrêt qu'elle a failli
en mourir donc
comme a dit benjamin castaldi elle a
quand même pas mal de casseroles au cul
elle m'a harcelée sur les réseaux
sociaux a essayé de m'atteindre en
parlant de mon père qui est décédé en
d'ailleurs s'il vise si tu me regardes
j'ai un message pour toi mon père il est
mort en 2013 tu as voulu parler de lui
eh ben il est au paradis et te pisse au
cul
ah oui d'accord c'est une folle une
[ __ ] c'est tout ce que j'ai à dire sur
cette grossesse a une gueule de
sorcières loana elle ne veut plus voir
ta gueule de sorcière qui est accusé
c'est donc car l'amour au sénat
candidate emblématique de l'émission
télé réalité les marseillais c'est ça
car la mort aux cons a tous découvert
dans les marseillais south africa ça
fait quelques années maintenant c'est
devenu un personnage culte accusé ça
c'est un fait on peut pas nier par
énormément de marceille et jusqu'à
junien tanti qui est le pilier d'avoir
fait de la sorcellerie au travers d'une
sorcière réputé à marseille apparemment
pour nuire à des candidats pour faire
annuler des mariages prétextant vouloir
être la star la numéro une
briller c'est grave ça va jusqu'à mettre
les personnes qui travaillent avec elle
dans la sauce ça s'appelle un
envoûtement de ruines
ça coûte de 5000 à 50000 euros qu'elle
aurait payé pour ça alors je ne dis pas
qu'elle a payé mais je connais
personnellement des gens qui payent pour
ça je vais pas vous mentir notamment
deux séances de sorcellerie sur cédric
impliquant des poupées vaudou dans
laquelle une voyante exécute un rituel
pour s'en prendre à deux autres
candidates de télé réalité regarder ces
deux vidéos en premier mais quittait
définitivement w9 et la production et se
fasse virer de me dire ils devront se
séparer de miles a rapidement et
instantanément et que car l'art de
vienne et vienne à tout jamais la
première des candidates de télé les
lacets vaudou il paraît qu'il ya des
trucs beaucoup plus grave remarque que
ce qu'on a vu comme les prévisions à
l'attaqué les trucs sur les gens vont
etc
ou alors j'ai eu ton rédac'chef par
pudeur et par respect de certaines
personnes qui me sont proches
je ne posterai pas ce genre de choses
d'accord c'est vraiment pas s'acharner
sur l occasion c'est quelqu'un qui a
fait ses propres décisions qui en assume
les conséquences en tout cas je l'espère
parce qu'elle n'a pas daigné le fait que
ce soit c'est audio samou
qui a été reportée sur mes réseaux
sociaux j'en prends l'entière
responsabilité effectivement maintenant
moi je fais juste que de donner
l'information je prends pas parti je ne
suis pas là pour bien évidemment tirer
sur l'ambulance comme on dit et c'est ce
que j'ai fait mon travail entre
guillemets et blogueurs
[Musique]